hello calculator fancy is a bit of a
unusual one today people have been
sending in calculators for me to unbox
which is very sweet of them I think some
people have calculators they think
should be unboxed by a professional and
it's very consider of them to send them
in so I'm going to go for the record of
most calculators unboxed in a video
sight unseen so let's get into it
first sharpest one we've been sent in
here at the South Korean associated
regions calculator appreciation society
for professionals and amateurs and no
indication where or who has sent this in
so let's I mean this is more of a
calculator I'm bagging so far but I'm
going to allow it well padded so it
doesn't get damaged it's come with a
note please funny clothes free
calculators which I hope you will
unblock over the time for that and
frankly three is cheating of somebody
going to unbox one of these we're either
going to do the scientific calculator
with cover we're going to do the home
and office scientific calculator or we
will do the Wilko scientific calculator
make sure you get your sums right vote
now
yep it's the Wilko so let's get into
that one let's pop this thing open using
scissors for when you're doing speed
unboxing I mean you know I like my
specialist tools but sometimes you just
need a multi-tool for everything and we
are in ok in no time for instructions in
a speed unboxing is it a cover yeah okay
it is it all it's got a little stand
that's nice and let's fire it up so
we'll do a simple test to open all the
way around it's a root 2 equals x root 2
equals 2 it works ok you can see how
someone saw the calculator and thought
this this would be a good one to unboxed
at this what a drab little kit there's
very little going on here in this
particular calculator and so I don't
think it wants any further tests I'm
impressed that someone had the
enthusiasm to send it in but I mean it's
just it's not it's it's it's no gak Co
is what I'm trying to say here so we'll
pop that
in the not particularly exciting pile
and move on to whatever this one is okay
and we have all this is exciting it
comes in a smaller unmarked box Wow what
could it be I mean I'm not fluent in all
barcodes so that I mean if you are
fluent in but then barcodes spoiler
alert that's already given away what's
going to happen but I don't know so it's
okay right oh my goodness already okay
it's not a rectangle so I'm already more
exposed than what that it's a keyboard
okay well let's test it first before we
get too excited how does it even turn
how's it turn on
is it solar-powered needs more luck
nothing light okay where I can and it's
on alright so if we give it enough
charge I feel like we should do like the
harmonic series what are we going to do
five times six okay it works okay so
it's a straightforward stuff with clear
on okay on doubles is clear that's not
very useful off is off on his con is on
and doesn't play any sounds so if it
played music as I was typing I'd be
impressed but sadly it doesn't they were
keyboard calculator
up next a Oh hopefully labeled this is
the box that through useful think I've
done enough unboxings to recognize a box
when I see one so let's get although use
electrical tape which is a nice touch
obviously professional circumstances I
wouldn't just be hacking at it with
scissors and ripping it open but given
we're just doing you know a fun little
unboxing of one of the amateurs have
sent in with a letter number file I'm
having to present you the staff device a
device that looks and behaves like a
normal digital clock if you hold down
the middle button while turning it on so
it becomes a calculator oh my goodness
oh wow this looks this looks dangerous
it comes in bits how on earth did this
not get flagged up by the post this
would not look good on an x-ray so okay
and that's all that we've got all the
pieces
seems to be the main body of it this is
a dangerously homemade-looking
power supply I don't wow I mean it must
be legitimate they've written it on in
tip X and the European socket very
little something in the name of my
organization which starts self sorry and
associated regions which would indicate
I'm doing this in England and I'm unable
to plug that in because we have Queens
voltage over here until I can't plug
that into it is this European socket
warranted work I believe we had a vote
on this recently so I'm going to file
this away for further investigation up
next okay this one's comes via Amazon
let's cancel there okay that was a very
straightforward this is almost a trivial
unboxing it's just open oh okay no
there's more legal still not fully
worthy of an unboxing yet and we have
well Texas Instruments okay someone has
sent us in a Texas Instruments because
on people get very upset that in America
all their calculators come from Texas
and we don't tend to have many over here
in South sorry so an associate Regents
so someone is finally cracked and sent
me in a TI the TI 30x - ass that's an
unnecessary level of versions that's
been through without a correct name so
let's turn it on and all it already
comes with a calculation preloaded so
it's already got two asterisks ^
asterisk times tan of something that's
to help people if you're using it and
you're not familiar with doing
calculations as an example one or maybe
in the factory that's just that that's a
Texan testing it or actually if you
rotate it it's like a little smiley face
I appreciate all the feedback everyone
gives however misguided it may be and I
know everyone wants us to do more Texas
Instruments so we will do we've heard
you you voted with your calculators we
will do a Texas calculator
special so I will get a whole bunch
we'll have a look at some don't worry we
will get around to Texas Instruments
thank you for sending it in okay and
this one
I mean unboxing it is trivial we can
already see it this was actually it
wasn't posted which is why it's already
open this one someone came and gave it
to me at the Manchester Science Festival
so they wake up as it here is a
calculator pen so let's get in there and
have a closer look at it and I there are
no surprises what we saw on the outside
it's exactly what we all look at the
instructions there has to be a new
record for the compact and efficient
placement of instructions and looking at
no unnecessary information I don't even
use both sides there like that's all we
need why print double-sided when you can
just fold it in half afterwards and cram
it in there and they vary UK patent on
they figured you know someone else is
going to try and beat them to market so
the crossover pen calculator market it
says auto power off and it's very
efficient the moment I turn it on it's
off again so is there no battery in that
I mean if only there was some other way
to use this without all there's not
there's a pen right so obviously I can
to the pen pen doesn't work the pen is
also also auto off what is this
can we commit we should better get in
there dude Wow so it's got ink in there
maybe it's just been okay so it was a
fair Nick ever gave this to me what I'm
saying to question how much they really
liked me so I mean look at that this is
clear this isn't aged this is an aged
product I don't know how this went so
long and people are able to resist
opening it to get out the calculator pen
this is clearly a product of a legal
loophole somewhere it's like you're not
let a calculator but you can bring in a
pen or you have to do all your
mathematical working out by pen and
they've gone not a problem I will do all
my working out bike pen right so there
you I mean full points for creativity
but
you have to take it into the shop and
get it looked at properly because this
is a vintage model and it's gonna need a
proper refurbishment and a going-over
before it's in a state for me to unbox
and review it here we go once at the
world record so next one up another
anonymous little sack I get into this oh
my goodness
second mystery box and so again if you
know your barcodes them up your spoiler
they're all my goodness it's transparent
okay okay that's kind of cool okay it's
a guard it's a guide everyone it's okay
I can remove that safely and there's no
way that's gonna work there's no way I
don't know what I'm pressing clear what
oh my goodness
often my desk is just dense with working
out and notes about calculators and all
sorts of math and you go well what am I
going to put my character I want to
cover up some of my mouth now you can
put it down and you're not you're barely
losing any of the mass you had available
before so I can get up quite handy and I
guess as a professional unboxer if I've
got another calculator I want to unbox
and I want to do some calculations at
the same time so I'm not under Lee I can
calculate I can unbox two at once like
I'm barely obscuring the one behind it
okay this one has already been opened
because it wasn't labeled as the
calculator on the outside and so I
opened it thinking it was normal post
and oh my goodness and this is it it was
the Casio data count 100 and oh this is
intriguing you can schedule a telephone
call to tell someone a secret I mean it
look like a particularly nice narrow
thing but should this situation ever
occur you can do some calculations at
the same time this because this is a new
generation of calculators so the box is
already open that it is still here
I mean it's missing missing a little tab
there which is a bit it's a bit sad but
it's got the what on earth operation
manual haven't got time for that in the
speed unboxing it's got is that a note
is that all okay it's the receipt from
the original purchase okay that's quite
nice so someone has bought this cow
you later in December 8 so the 14th of
December a year that ends in 8th
I mean I'm gonna guess it's oh there's a
tap oh thank goodness
okay so there's that missing turns from
the end there so this has been purchased
I assume in 1988 I could be wrong this
is why you should always use the full
with the complete timecode various
appoint let's not use that someone's
paid 17 pounds 75 P back in the day from
this from John and that's actually I
mean I know a lot of people try hard
when they want to be a serious
calculator collector and they send them
in I try and be encouraging and I always
say keep all your documentation if you
can't show the Providence of the
calculator what is the point of having
it in your collection and someone here
is actually kept the original sales
receipt from a branch of the John Lewis
Partnership so well done someone out
there you're you're halfway to being a
serious calculator appreciator I mean
I'm a little confused partly because
this is a very new device and partly
because I appeared of woken up in the
year 2041 which I mean I had I mean time
flies when you're unboxing calculators
but that is ridiculous this is here
because in some calculators if you press
up up down down left right a bit you
know you can unlock special modes to the
square root test times 2 square root
equals eat nothing what times oh I
didn't I it's probably before to
realistic buttons Wow equals RF is
rounded down that's not good so I'm
going to put that in my curiosity pile
think you've ever sent that in and I
will have a closer look at one birth is
going on there and maybe it maybe I can
tease out its secrets who knows and I'll
keep the original tab can go in there
with a receipt that I mean that is a
pretty complete collection I'm impressed
and finally in our attempt the eighth's
calculator because you always do powers
of two and you
sixteen I mean no no human could unlock
sixteen taxes oh haha
so some comedian out there I mean I
don't really go into the jokes and
comedy that someone thinks they're
hysterical and they sent me in an abacus
oh I almost think I shouldn't even give
it the the decent even unboxing but I am
professional and I refuse to let down my
standards okay so this sticks clear
entry function isn't working properly
some of the previous entry is still in
there yeah that's a hard reset and what
is this someone's ah there's a
manufacturing default and the display is
there's like a dead pixel on the display
of this abacus flip note two dead pixels
okay so I guess I can turn into a
calculation with this let's let enter in
just this maybe that's seven and I'm
going to divide to 1/7 and then multiply
by seven again so there you are an
abacus well done from up there thinks
they're hilarious and I guess I mean is
it's quite a funny joke sending in an
abacus I can appreciate that that
someone out there is a comedian but a
calculator unboxing video is no time for
joking around so it's just it's not
appropriate but thank you to everyone
who did send in proper serious
calculators it's been fun doing a speed
unboxing we'll be back with some proper
serious unboxing soon this should be
equal to the main tricky what age group
is behind that well clearly from the
front children and amusement know hang
on yeah it's a suitable only for Nobel
Prize with anything that we want they're
putting them all back in Altered so here
it is there so we're going to be into
the wall one hundreds